karten mai angenommen die stadt muss
das gerade mit den kollegen
planmäßig hebt der jumbo um 22 uhr 10 ab
geht davon einzuhalten hochbetrieb auch
wie intersport die bewegung an der
ansagen abend
verlassen gerade die reiseflughöhe der
aussichten für einen baldigen feierabend
so lange haben mit der zeit gewöhnt man
geschlafen ja aber zu kurz
ausgebrannt ist 8 deswegen sagen man
taktik sturm in frankfurt hoffentlich
gedacht sein doch morgen das
heimat einmal hierher wenn die leute und
ja das auf jeden fall man gewöhnt sich
gesagt als getan man muss immer was der
nicht weil man nichts weiß gemalt ist
laufen sonst werden der glanz griffin
bisschen höher als heuer weiter unter
vorher rassen überträgt den falschen weg
weiter hinten sitzt hat jedoch oft pech
nur sagen bei uns noch so egal ob die
und mitmachen flugzeit nach dem dänen
sich für die aus- und wieder zu hause
zwei das heißt es eine gute zeit um
heiße braut vielflieger thomas hat glück
tiefschlaf geweckt der arme es ist ja
unwetter über buenos aires ist der
dpa zu boden zu 1000 meter die poren der
der service ist erledigt wir schlafen
moments wach werden aber wenn jetzt ein
bevor es ende kollege sebastian
pause schneller vorbei als einem lieb
pausen am zielort dann könnte sich die
schlafgemach piloten befindet sich
über den wolken sebastian buchberger
sofort einschlägt also bei mir ist es so
wird zum tanken zwei stunden vor abflug
nachtflugs werden fortlaufend sämtliche
anders
frischen später nachdem der oper die
weil man ja mein mann kommt gemeinsam an
start katzenjammer am nächsten morgen
so werden an bord problemchen gelöst die
zeigt sie mit dem taxi durch buenos
hat jetzt vier tage pause bevor sie
dabei wird sich auch gleich auf
nachdruck zurück ein schönes wochenende
bleiben konstant gut schlafen oder hast
festgestellt dass jetzt noch eine stunde
wahrscheinlich oder service nachher
da ist das wetter ganz gut zum anschauen
sich so ein bisschen an diese geschichte
frankfurt um 23 uhr greift wollen alle
ja das gute greußen
schnell
für den riesenflieger
nacht auch für die kabinenbesatzung eine
geburt zu mensch und tier feierstimmung
langsam die kräfte zu bekommen das geht
sind nötig um den jumbo in die luft zu
du was mitbekommen auch nach neun
jetzt wieder hellwach und stücks zeit
flug von deutschland ist in buenos aires
kabinen zweier ruheraum für die perser
man weiß was einen erwartet das ist
oder man versucht es mit dem geist der
jetzt um die uhrzeit wenn die spd ist
liegen gelassen
genau weiss gab es einen oder nicht die
bisschen wegen den augen wenn man so
flieger strich
recht kurzen pausen deutlich dass sich
in der gew die küche im flugzeug reist
automatisch wenn der flieger hochgeht
dreihundert dieser motor hin zu bringen
ganz gut wenn man angeschlagen haben
stunden in jumbos im cockpit höchste
cci cent
erfahrungen eines viel fliegers sagen
himmel voller flieger die auf besseres
den 20
endlich wechsel zu geben
im cockpit alles im blick und die nacht
jetzt wird buenos aires erkundet von den
nachts um halb vier alles rot im flieger
szenarien durchgegangen
mit ihr an bord kapitäns herr david und
darf nun schlummern bei 9 150
direkt hinter cockpit das bett eine
vorbei die sonne jetzt auch entschädigt
wahrscheinlich aber sieht es ganz schön
dann am tag vorbei und dann haben wir
wieder wahllos mit anderen anderen
weit so lange weil ich noch defizite in
crew nicht so von einem marathon von
umsorgt werden take off für die
stunden in der luft vom hotel in buenos
20 jahren ab jetzt geht es relativ
macht meistens im konzert aus wenn er
dafür erst mal so eine kleine qual
aufgeteilt haben aber italiens so
im cockpit erreichen inzwischen
während über frankfurt die nacht
stunden wird die maschine in der luft
buchberger fliegt mit der show die wie
erst nach der landung
sein kann gut geschlafen und jetzt fit
kostenfreie da hatte ich so ein bisschen
gelangt nicht richtig gekümmert auf
lange durch die nacht geflogen ist dann
polizeieinsatz neben dem steakhouse doch
seine wahl gibt es auch noch wenn bayer
kann verschläft den überflug über
schlechtes wetter über dem flughafen und
gelandet ein letzter stopp auf dem
anstrengenden flug gibt es für die crew
und wider der sonnenaufgang verspricht
herausforderung und jeder hat sein
gerade noch die gäste aus dann wird noch
ich freue mich sehr über dem atlantik
noch abheben stau auf dem taxi break
traube der einen in den schlaf der mann
aires jetzt die pilotin ricarda tabelle
kriegen die 352 passagiere wollen
ausweichflughäfen gecheckt das wetter
wetter gewartet und mit mir vorher
stimmung muss ja auch noch zwölf stunden
die chefs der kabinenbesatzung für die
sichtweite und um acht uhr morgens in
nach unserer zeit schon frei geworden
will dann wird es sehr lange halten
kennen erholt sich gemeinsam und ist
aufmerksamkeit herrschen laufende
friesland brasilien receiver und die
letzte vorbereitungen für den flug durch
anbricht und wann man von haye über 13
liege vom vorgänger vorgewärmt die
stundenkilometern in 10.000 metern höhe
sagt ok betreffen und will dass es da
erholen neue eindrücke verdrängen die
wachwechsel im cockpit die kurz gebucht
auch im cockpit croissants und marmelade
die nächsten zwei stunden über den
352 mahlzeiten müssen zeitgleich fertig
klickt hier was im kopf und ich lasse
und vermittele er ist es doch einfacher
tag sie die kuh vor allem eins von
aires bis zum eigenen bett in frankfurt
auswendig die farben sind immer
53 und von wem gäbe es bessere tipps
ricarda tabelle fliegt durch die nacht
kabinencrew als starter gibt's nüsschen
vielversprechend
anstrengungen des volkes nicht mehr viel
brasilien
nur noch eine traum destination die crew
wir können uns das mal ausdrücken wie
muss wie man so hinten sitzt heißt
werden die augen einfach freundlicher
flieger und produzieren nonstop durch
halten keine zeit für schlechte laune
dieses stück hier über dem atlantik das
zu viel verkehr verzögert den feierabend
das wetter ist wieder ruhig der die cent
zuhause noch wenige meter bis zum
rollfeld endlich ein freier parkplatz
deutschland 3 uhr morgens haben das okay
jumbo beherbergt bis zu 362 menschen
landung wird endlich der flughafen in
nur ganz vorne wird gemacht die kollegen
first officer sebastian buchberger
berührungsängste für flugbegleiter ein
eigenes rezept gegen die müdigkeit und
und dann ist man eigentlich schon in der
und werden am ersten abend verfehlt hat
überprüft gerade auf der strecke buenos
argentinien die lande freigabe wir
triebwerk grund gibt es verkehr in der
lässt das nächste zeit nicht zwei-
buenos aires das hotelbett
kollegen geht's rauf kuschelig wie
sich dabei durch die weltgeschichte ja
atlantik ricarda tabelle darf schlafen
vier stunden flug sind geschafft das
einfach durch die gegend
wunderschön wie blau grün wenn die sonne
und das ist ein bisschen wie
die abschlüsse checkliste gelesen und
baldigen feierabend die
die kontrolle ab und erkennt parallelen
sind es sogar gut 16 stunden einchecken
britsche wird selbst gemacht weit
normalerweise man keine wahl hat weil
zu spüren
wechsel mit ihrem kollegen direkt nach
endlich pause für ricarda tamale des
wir uns hier wecken lassen wollen zehn
von 1 einfach trainieren und es macht
vor der pause kommt noch das wetter und
sein chef hier im regen ist die
feierabend während es für die kollegen
sogar montevideo ist als
in der regel wenig möglichkeiten die
fremdwort neue kontakte werden schnell
einen solch langen flug zu bekommen als
lage verschlafen
wer das essen nicht gerade verschläft
bei einem solch langen flug ist jedoch 1
heißt es ist schon eine relativ lange
und
fast 14 stunden flug liegen vor ihnen
wüstenlandschaften afrikas und das
luft und wie immer hält das wetter die
schmerzhaft aber es ist dann muss ich
dann geht es ins hotel freuen uns sehr
der sinkflug beginnt der längste nonstop
bienenwaben im sechser kämmerchen doch
minuten vorher viertelstunde vorher muss
fahren am meisten über die stadt kennen
mittelmeer erreicht auch wenn der flug
die tag und nacht
auch perser toni hat jetzt endlich pause
aufgeht das ist schon schön entschädigt
die luft hat irgendwie so noch 50 50
und sicherheitskontrolle da muss jeder
sogenannte dem aus auch wenn der flug
aires wird es sehr sehr lange über
nonstop über den atlantik von frankfurt
einen freud des anderen leid an gut
frankfurt zum greifen nah
strecke wir hätten dann ein flughafen
ausweichflughafen im gespräch
zwei stunden geschlafen kapitän sergiu
noch eine stunde bis zum start ricardo
jetzt erst los geht nach diesem
der hat die wahl hähnchen oder pasta wer
am abend trifft sich die besatzung nach
die vorbereitungen beginnen nach fünf
zu passagieren mit flugangst wenn ein
klick in der business class gibt es noch
von einem vielflieger mit rund status
atlasgebirge nordafrikas leuten den
darüber jetzt hat die crew 48 stunden
rotation im cockpit
der ersten klasse nur zwei schritte
ich mich lieber länger schlafen das
nachtruhe trifft nicht wirklich so sagen
erst mal wieder daran gewöhnen dass die
nicht und wenn dann immer im vollen teil
durch auch die kunst wieder im cockpit
finde ich das beste einfach immer laufen
warteschleife stadt landebahn nach einem
der lohn für die strapazen der nacht der
gerade die gemeinsamen erkundungen der
ruhig scheint helfer und den notfall
bis buenos aires erreicht wird einfach
doch jetzt 30 minuten vor dem abflug
denn was wäre die dakar zum beispiel und
noch zwölf stunden laut aufs essen
am wichtigsten flüssigkeit und auch wenn
die eine zu wacht zum schlafen der
sonne kommt ja ja klar die habe ich auch
heißt ich habe dann zehn minuten ab dem
kann man jetzt für so eine art
nach buenos aires und zurück über
menschen die quasi im flieger leben und
endspurt einigen
weiter mit dem schlafen gute später
liebig ist wieder aus der pause zurück
der arbeit an sich kennen und erzählt
gewappnet ricarda tabelle
porzellan auf dem tisch aber das hilft
tamura check den flieger von außen hier
irgendwie sowas bevorzugt wird dann
tagen des uranus eines umlaufs bald zu
warten will niemand für die crew ist das
fremde sind für die erholung der kuchen
kein urlaubs feeling mehr der jumbo w
und beobachten was ist hier so gibt es
dann erst wieder in südamerika recife
moment wo sie mich denken dass ich hier
entsprechen ja ich hätte ihnen schon
einsteigen und losfliegen ging nicht die
sonne und dem feierabend entgegen
paar mädels skifahren gewesen und das
im cockpit die puppe der dritte mann
andere noch müde theateralltag bei
noch vier stunden bis frankfurt von
es verlockend ist um auf kopfschmerzen
von den erfahrenen vergangener flüge es
die retter sind auf den flughäfen in
kommt hier nur der rest an wer auf
auch nicht gegen schlaflosigkeit denn
hause genug von fern
muss alles stimmen keine delle kein
verzichtbar unverzichtbar in argentinien
dann sind sehr wichtig dass man schläft
essen nicht mehr verlaufen mannschaft
fliegen das trader sind buenos aires ist
vorne jeder bereitstehen muss aber das
gebändigt werden
das kann sehr gut sein wenn jetzt hier
zu sehen gibt es in buenos aires genug
zu verzichten sollte über den wolken
strecke wird geplant das wetter
nachtflügen das mit dem fuß macht
eine wackelige landung steht bevor der
waren 3 türer und der saß ich da hinten
müdigkeit ricarda tabelle wird den staat
den wolken ein flug marathon für die
jetzt an ohne pause die kabinen crew ist
nicht bei jedem macht es einfach klick
über 70 meter lang 352 passagiere und
kratzer keine flüssigkeiten die hier
nummer sicher gehen will bestellt vor
diese hohen wolken sind kann kanzler
saal
state geheimtipps werden von kuh zu kuh
alkoholfrei getrunken werden leichter
geschenkt haben
drin hatte nicht meine tür wo ich
gran canaria und da kam das machen wir
abflug ein spezial menu rabbiner extras
und zu schauen ob filmklassiker oder
durchführen die steuer flächen die das
ist gewährt jetzt in deutschland 20 nach
auch wackeln momentan sieht es aber so
sturm ist entgegen dem wetterbericht vor
nicht hingehören die kontrolle mit
gesamte crew faszinierende ansichten
jederzeit hätte ausgehen können das hat
weitergegeben und lieb gewonnen ja die
aus als müssten wir das nicht erwarten
hier eingezeichnet ist die strecke über
375 tonnen startgewicht flug lh 511 ist
höhenruder werten getestet alles bewegt
den flieger in frankfurt abgekommen nach
bloßem auge ist unverzichtbar auch wenn
klassische küchenmaschinen
dann schon ein beklemmendes gefühl und
jeder von uns wird zwei mal standen sich
immer auf der strecke das wäre einfach
da kann ich das dann nachvollziehen denn
sich frei flug lh 510 ist ready for take
13 stunden in der luft noch einmal
man weiß es natürlich nie das wetter
sehen wo ist das wetter gut am flughafen
das zweite mal wieder durch nur kurze
und ich glaube man kommt so langsam mit
der flieger ein alter bekannter ist
die kanarischen inseln
ready for take off über 100.000 apps
ins bett legen und natürlich hat man als
höchste konzentration
passagiere vielleicht flugangst haben
hält sich auch nicht mal genau die karte
wo könnte waren im notfall jederzeit
also schön wär's jetzt nicht wenn das
die knapp 300 tonnen der 747 werden von
off bevor das nachtflugverbot in
am ende dieser zehn umlaufenden kollegen
pausen mehr als ein nickerchen ist da
der zeit einfach im übung dass man dann
land nun
die jetzt wie hier von meteorologen
der schneide koloss bleibt in
weil sie eingeschlossen sind und nicht
wetter sehr schlecht wäre in buenos
bekommen haben das muss man dann sehen
doch auch sebastian buchberger pause ist
den sturmböen hin und her geschaukelt
nicht drin der kapitän sergiu david geht
selber entscheiden können wann sie das
unterschiede seien
aires und wir vom gewicht her nicht sehr
argentinien doch obligatorisch der
flugzeug verlassen können aber hier
noch zwölf stunden in der luft doch
der pilot muss gegensteuern endlich
gleich vorbei wahrscheinlich aus dem
viele extra angreifen kraftstoff
aber erstmal schluss stand dann auch
in die koje ricarda tabelle übernimmt
besuch am grab der argentinischen
fühle ich mich jetzt wohl hier doch
mitnehmen könnten
schon ein ziel vor augen
volksheldin evita perón hier hat die
jetzt nicht so viel gehupt und taktisch
ansonsten bin ich mit der maschine
das cockpit die nacht zum tage machen
das war jetzt nicht so gut aber wir
gefahren wie in indien
wieder ein bisschen dann feierabend
bestimmt auch schon vielleicht 25 mal
trainings sache
genießen das wetter nicht
das schön hier doch das geht kürzere
crew genug zeit land und leute
haben jetzt glück das wetter ist in
konnte mir das am anfang auch überhaupt
ordnung und wir können auch jetzt ein
geflogen
kennenzulernen
währenddessen freuen sich die passagiere
doch das ist nicht immer so
nicht vorstellen dass wir jetzt gerade
routine darf nicht aufkommen denn wenn
bisschen extra zusätzlichen kraftstoff
auch auf das essen noch kein
mitnehmen
buenos aires mit 13 25
während des fluges etwas nicht stimmt
argentinisches steak aber flugzeug kost
gutes wetter gute laune während die drei
einfach rechts ranfahren tätigt und bei
solange ich die nacht fliegen aber das
für viele der beginn des urlaubs
faszinierend wie tomatensaft der
ansonsten haben wir oft auch nur 24
piloten den flugplan besprechen die
ist eine reine mentale
einem so langen flug von frankfurt nach
sache die eigentlich
buenos aires ist selbst eine landung
akkordarbeit
flugbegleiter die abläufe an bord
stunden zeit das nutzt man meistens
352 essen zubereitet und verteilt
nicht immer möglich fast sechs stunden
sicherheit speisen service die kennt
nur von der inneren einstellung
wird der turbo über den atlantik fliegen
langsam ist ein für eigene erholung die
zeitgleich und geburtstage gehen 10.000
eigentlich ist also das ist jetzt
ohne möglichkeit einen nahen flughafen
sich nicht jeder flug beginnt mit neuen
48 stunden sind rum es geht wieder
vollkommen in ordnung natürlich gibt es
meter über der erde bei percy toni auch
kollegen so soll auf den langen flügen
anzusteuern doch die faszination für
zurück zwischen fernweh und heimweh
irgendwann moment wo man dann flächen
nicht unter lesen ist in den soll mehr
ein bisschen müde ist aber ich finde ich
gemischte gefühle war der crew so geht
routine vermieden werden jeder flug ist
ihren flieger ist für ricarda tabelle
jetzt sehr fit und
auch nach 17 berufsjahren und gebrochen
ihr zu hause freut man sich ja ich da
ich denke mal jeder peter somit seine
eigene einstellung an während des
lange nächte nimmt man dafür in kauf das